what up space fam goals in here from
anime up pro back at it again to discuss
the latest developments in the bordeaux
story and this time i'm talking about
the official translation
so a lot of things have been cleared up
and we got a bunch to talk about
if you do enjoy seeing naruto and boruto
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming then the best thing you
could do
is smash that like button and share this
video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto slash
boruto videos so if you haven't make
this the day you subscribe
as you wait for the next porto chapter
or video to drop feel free to check out
my growing naruto slash boruto playlist
where i got videos about the hokage
all tsutsuki aluzumaki and most recently
all akatsuki members and their powers
explained
links to the playlist and to the new
akatsuki video can be found in the
description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
again we have that beautiful cover for
this chapter of naruto in
baryon mode and the chapter titled
baryon mode has stayed the same
in the official translations this is a
higher quality image of naruto's new
mode and again
i gotta mention how much i love the form
it's not crazy different
but different enough to be very
impactful and now we just got masashi
kishimoto's
and mikio ikemoto's credits on this
chapter
since as i mentioned the last video ukyo
kodachi
has handed the matana boruto so to speak
to the original naruto creator kishimoto
kishimoto had a much more offhands role
before
more so just supervising kodachi's
script while now it seems that kishimoto
is doing the story scripts and original
drafts while ikemoto will keep
doing the art with the original creator
back in the driver's seats during this
chapter things have really gone
full throttle so let's jump into the
fight naruto entered his new deadly mode
that was supposed to cost him his life
and everyone was shocked by it in the
last chapter this form was covered in
smoke to build up the height
but here we see his full face not too
different
but different enough for us to know that
it's a new form and the tails in the
back are a nice touch as well
ishiki is shocked that naruto had an ace
like this up his sleeve
and wonders why he didn't use it before
and sasuke feels left out too he notices
the tremendous amount of chakra
and wonders why naruto never told him
about it but as we know
naruto didn't even know about it since
kurama never told him
and boruto is shocked as well obviously
then we get the official explanation for
the form
kurama says to naruto think of it as
nuclear fusion similar to how the sun
produces energy
and of course naruto is like what's that
and i love how smart kurama is here he
just says the theory doesn't matter
and dumbs it down kurima's chakra and
naruto's chakra serve as kernels to
produce a whole
other new type of energy it's different
from kurama mode and sage of six paths
mode
from the very root of it since the other
modes involve taking chakra that you
acquire from elsewhere
and just using it but in this case the
raw materials to create this energy
are their chakras until one or both of
their lives run out
this is an important nuance in the
official translation here so there's a
possibility here that one person's
chakra may run out
first and i'm really hoping that we
don't somehow lose kurama here either
but otherwise this form is what i
thought it was it is pretty much burning
life energy and converting
it into massive power like escrinor's
the one ultimate mode
and as a result kurama mentions that
naruto shouldn't make any unnecessary
moves or have unnecessary thoughts even
because that's the way to keep this
baryon mode
going for as long as possible we jump to
ishiki who tells naruto he doesn't like
the look in naruto's eyes and really
he doesn't like his confidence he wants
him to be worried and cowering but
naruto's eyes look on straightforward
confidently and since ishiki views
himself as a superior being
this in and of itself is an insult to
him ishiki attacks but naruto has the
clear advantage
and this massive power boost should not
be underestimated
remember naruto and sasuke together were
defeated by a weaker ishiki and jigen's
body and now alone
naruto is beating the reincarnated and
much more powerful version of ishiki he
dodges his blows and lands his own hits
on ishiki with no problem sasuke doesn't
just say
they're even now he says that naruto's
actually
beating ishiki again this leap in power
puts him an insane amount ahead of
sasuke his former rival
but at the same time according to kurama
it comes at the ultimate cost naruto's
life
although now that things have been
explained by kurama i don't see why
naruto can't stop the mode before he
dies
kurama didn't mention that it's
irreversible and you can come out of all
other modes so we'll see
my only question is if naruto comes out
of it will his lifespan be shortened or
will he be able to rejuvenate the life
force
he burned through it feels like this
mode is mainly dangerous if they pass
the point of no return
when it's too late to stop it before
their lives burn out
ishiki tries his cube trick but naruto
doesn't even have to lift a hand to stop
them only his tails
in the meantime sasuke grabs boruto take
him away from the battlefield to a safer
place
and we get a pretty great moment where
naruto actually throws ishiki's q
back at him the latter dodges it but
only to be kicked down by the faster
naruto and keep in mind because it will
be important later
naruto is landing a lot of blows on
ishiki ishiki then tries to use his
black rods but naruto effortlessly stops
them with
one hand to sasuke's shock who says that
even with his shutting gone
he could barely track the rods let alone
stop them ishiki is real worried now
he's beat up and again he can't believe
that naruto could power up so
drastically so fast
just when naruto has the heavy lead we
jump to kawaki and the others
nothing big here but it is important
that they mention naruto's prosthetic
arm that he gave to kawaki
it's pointed out that naruto has been
sharing his chakra with kawaki
so he could use the arm at all times
he's constantly giving chakra to that
arm
and amano is surprised questioning if
there is no end to naruto's generosity
and this must hit kawaki hard
kauki does not like being a burden to
others so we know
that that might shape his future actions
and rationale as well
although he clearly hasn't been
portrayed as a bad guy
his unwillingness to be a burden to
others may inadvertently send him down
the wrong road where he distances
himself from others and eventually
becomes an enemy from naruto we've
definitely seen the recurring theme of
loneliness
and pain turning people into villains
but i'm getting ahead of myself for now
all we need to know
is that through the arm kawaki notices
that naruto is weakening and so here the
connection between the arm and naruto is
once again
being emphasized we then jump back to
naruto and he drops to what need he's
gasping for breath and his form seems
unsteady
sasuke notices his chakra rapidly
dropping
and boruto comments that he hurts all
over before he passes out
naruto mentions that the energy cost is
even steeper than he thought
and then ishiki realizes what's
happening he comments that the rapid
jump in power was a life-shortening
sacrificial gamble
this makes more sense than the
unofficial translation i read where
ishiki commented that naruto could win
at the cost of his life but in reality
what's going on here is that ishiki is
implying that naruto lost his bet and
he'll die without winning which makes
much more sense but just as ishiki is
being cocky
he starts spitting out blood and he
drops down he's confused why
and here we have another important
detail that i didn't get from the
unofficial leaks
while naruto says the real fight begins
now
to see which one of them dies first we
get a convo
between kurama and naruto and kurma says
the power of this
mode definitely exceeds ishiki but not
enough to beat him before they end up
dying
but and here's the crucial detail the
downside that the mode shortens their
life
is actually key to the plan not only is
their life force being shaved off
every time they come into contact with
ishiki with punches and kicks
this mode shaves off his lifespan as
well so his limited time is decreasing
more and more
as the fight goes on a very cool detail
that i didn't get from the unofficial
translations and this makes this form
all the more op
yeah it still shaves off the user's life
energy but it also does the same for the
opponent
which is very useful especially in this
case while naruto was shaving off
ishiki's lifespan
he got him down from 20 hours to less
than 30 minutes
and then we get another quote that i was
waiting to read in the official
translation
the boxer quote kurama says don't think
about taking ishiki down
only focus on getting in your attacks
just like a boxer aiming to win by
decision
in this way he will shave off the rest
of ishiki's life
before theirs runs out again implying
that they might actually be able to
survive this
the fight keeps going and naruto gets
hit after hit
as ishiki says it's not the force that's
the issue
but the fact that every time he gets hit
more and more time is shaved off
naruto is weakening and ishiki gets him
by the throat but at the same time
he only has less than 10 minutes left
now and i'm guessing that even holding
naruto by the throat
is shaving more and more off of ishiki's
lifespan
he needs to prepare kawaki as his future
vessel right away
and naruto says it's too late he doesn't
have enough time
and here is where that earlier
conversation comes into play
ishiki starts laughing and says he will
be the last one standing not the lesser
species
and this just seems like a constant
thing of tsutsuki villains have to do
keep talking about how superior they are
as a species but the point is a portal
appears where kawaki is
and brings him to the battlefield to
everyone's shock
even the usually stoic amado is like no
way and is noticeably sweating
although he still seems pretty calm
compared to everyone else maintaining
some of that calm cool and collected a
model-ness
even in the worst case situation kawaki
is now on the battlefield and ishiki
points out that it was because that arm
was functioning with naruto's chakra
that link allowed him to detect kawaki
and drag him here at the last moment
but before he puts his karma on kawaki
boruto awakens
now the translation i read made it seem
like it was the jogon in boruto's eyes
which would be cool
but it could be momoshiki taking over
like he did before
again we can't be sure because boruto's
pupil did look like this
in the time skip scene against kawaki
and in the manga there has been no black
around the jogon
so it could be it but the expression of
borto's face
does kind of look like momoshiki might
be running the show
so we will have to wait for the next
chapter to know for sure the
significance of this opening eye but
either way
whether we see the powerful momoshiki
boruto or whether we get the joke on
it is gonna be extremely intense i'm
saying it again this is boruto at its
best right here
and what an amazing chapter for
kishimoto to come back for
let me know if this is your favorite
chapter yet in the comments it is
definitely up there among my favorites
for me
and that is it for this video if you do
enjoy seeing naruto and boruto videos on
this channel and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is smash that like button and share this
video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future naruto slash
boruto videos
so if you haven't yet make this the day
you subscribe
and as you wait for the next boruto
chapter or video to drop feel free to
check out our growing naruto slash
portal playlist where i got videos about
okage olotutsuki aluzumaki and most
recently all akatsuki members and their
powers explained
links to the playlist and the new
akatsuki video can be found in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
twigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans ingrata the
world
acquire respect liam thompson pate heffa
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tennelle
big buddhist rythean tungsten tarkis and
denki kaminari
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated overall champion
of the world steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky cricket xp
joel stanton with aura very gucci
jessica kayla font alicia actor hinokami
and water bonnie parks the red-haired
raven florian joanne garcia mcshamus
jack watches anime amanda c
deadly saint high school dxd73 matthew
cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already smashed and a bunch of
you have been doing that so thank you so
much to everyone who's joined the
channel as well
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer so whichever way
you support us you can get the same
great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you